This is 99% invisible. I'm Swan Rael. What makes you sound the way you do? Maybe you've been told that you speak like your mom, or that you laugh like your uncle. Maybe you sometimes slip back into an accent that reveals something about your past. Maybe you have a habit of matching the ways that other people speak when you want to make them more comfortable. Maybe you haven't thought about your voice.
这里是“百分之九十九隐形”。我是天鹅·雷尔。是什么让你拥有了现在的声音？也许有人对我说过，你的说话方式跟你妈妈很像，或者你的笑声跟你叔叔一模一样。也许你有时会不经意间流露出某种口音，透露出你过去的一些经历。也许当你想要让别人感到更自在时，你会习惯性地模仿别人的说话方式。也许你根本没怎么琢磨过自己的声音。
Or maybe you think about it all the time, because you have to. Voices are fascinating to me. The way a person's voice changes over time feels like a simple and overlooked act of magic. Whether intentionally or subconsciously, our voices are products of our environments as much as they are part of us. Today we're featuring a series that I'm excited to share with you. It's called Sounds Gay, a show about queer culture, community, and music. This is an episode that they did about voices, about a videotape, and about sisterhood. And after the episode Roman is gonna join me for a special conversation. I hope you dig it. Hi, I'm Melanie Ann, and in the next 30 minutes you're gonna get everything you need to develop a more feminine voice.
或者，你无时无刻不在琢磨它，因为你不得不这么做。声音对我有着巨大的吸引力。一个人声音随时间流逝而发生的变化，感觉就像是一个简单却被忽视的魔法奇迹。无论是有意还是无意，我们的声音既是环境的产物，也是我们自身的一部分。今天，我们要为您呈现一个我非常高兴能与大家分享的系列节目。它叫作《听上去像个同性恋》，是一档聚焦酷儿文化、社群与音乐的节目。这是他们制作的一期关于声音、关于一卷录像带、也关于姐妹情谊的节目。节目播出后，罗曼将加入我，与我进行一场特别的对话。希望你们会喜欢。嗨，我是梅兰妮·安，在接下来的 30 分钟里，你将获得培养更女性化声音所需的一切知识。
There's seven major areas I found to be real tools. You're not going to cover them all in great detail. If you're a trans woman in 2023 and you want to change your voice to sound more traditionally feminine, you have options. There are apps, YouTube videos, even online voice coaches. But if you were a trans woman in the 90s and you wanted to change your voice, you'd want to get your hands on a video tape like Melanie speaks. Over the course of her 45 minute tape, Melanie offers tips, vocal exercises, and plenty of encouragement. And she points out that there are many ways to sound feminine. Let me give you a couple of examples. First of all, look at Suzanne Plishette, And she points out that there are many ways to sound feminine. I'm Sarah Esacoff and this is Sounds Gay, a podcast about the intersection of music and queerness. This week we're talking about voices, not just vocals in a song,
我发现有七个主要领域是非常实用的工具。你不会详细了解所有这些内容。如果你是 2023 年的一名跨性别女性，并且想改变自己的声音，让它听上去更具传统女性的特质，你有很多选择。有各种应用程序、YouTube 视频，甚至还有在线声乐教练。但如果你是 90 年代的一名跨性别女性，并且想要改变自己的声音，你就会想要弄到一卷像梅兰妮录制的这种录像带。在长达 45 分钟的录像带中，梅兰妮提供了小贴士、发声练习以及大量的鼓励。她指出，让声音听上去女性化的方法有很多。我来给你们举几个例子。首先，看看苏珊·普里谢特，她指出，让声音听上去女性化的方法有很多。我是萨拉·埃萨科夫，这里是《听上去像个同性恋》，一档探讨音乐与酷儿身份交集的播客。本周我们探讨的是声音，不仅是歌曲中的唱腔，
but also speaking voices. The instrument I'm using to tell you this story right now. also speaking voices. The instrument I'm using to tell you this story right now. We get so much information from how people talk. We hear regional accents or slang, the rise and fall of emotion, the scratchiness of a night smoking in the back of a dive bar. But a trans person's voice might lead to unwanted exposure, even in the most mundane interactions. Buying a pack of gum can become a record scratch moment, where suddenly everyone's staring at you. Your voice can make you stand out when you desperately want to blend in. For decades, trans people, especially trans women whose voices don't change when they take
还有说话的声音。这就是我此时此刻用来向你讲述这个故事的乐器。还有说话的声音。这就是我此时此刻用来向你讲述这个故事的乐器。我们从人们的谈话中获取了大量的信息。我们能听出地方口音或俚语，情绪的起伏，以及在小酒馆后厅抽了一夜烟后声音的沙哑。但跨性别者的声音可能会导致不希望受到的曝光，即便是在最平淡无常的交流中。买一包口香糖都可能成为一个唱片卡壳的时刻，突然之间所有人都盯着你看。当你极力想要融入人群时，你的声音却会让你显得格外显眼。几十年来，跨性别者，尤其是那些在接受荷尔蒙治疗后声音不会发生改变的跨性别女性，一直在互相教导如何找到她们的新声音。而在 90 年代，其中一位负责传授经验的人是一位名叫梅兰妮的女性。今天我们要探讨的问题是：梅兰妮是如何帮助一代跨性别女性找到她们的声音的？她现在又在哪里？我从《听上去像个同性恋》的节目顾问兼“习惯动物”卡斯·阿代尔那里得知了“梅兰妮在说话”这卷录像带。你早餐吃什么？我早餐吃什么？
hormone therapy, have been teaching each other how to find their new voices. And in the 90s, one of the people doing the teaching was a woman named Melanie. Today we're asking, how did Melanie help a generation of trans women find their voices? And where is she now? I learned about Melanie Speaks from Soundsgate Consulting Producer and Creature of Habit, Cass Adair. What do you have for breakfast? What do I have for breakfast?
呃，鸡肉和红薯，这是我唯一的食物。卡斯是一位媒体研究教授，目前正在撰写一本关于跨性别历史和数字媒体的书。因此，他花了很多时间泡在跨性别者的历史档案里。做档案研究很大一部分工作就是阅读旧的通讯刊物和旧杂志，并对这些人物究竟是谁有一种大致的了解。梅兰妮正是在这些通讯刊物上为她的录像带做广告的。
Um, chicken and sweet potatoes, which is the only food that I eat. Cass is a media studies professor and is currently writing a book about transgender history and digital media. So he spends a lot of time in trans archives. A lot of what being an archive is is just reading old newsletters and old magazines and kind of getting a sense of like who the characters are. Melanie advertised her tape in these newsletters.
所以她是卡斯密切关注的主角之一。奇怪的是，她总是不断地被提及。比如，我会读一本在 2000 年代初出柜的人的传记，然后他们就会提到同一个人。所以我当时就想，哦，真奇怪。很显然，她是个相当了不起的人物。但与卡斯研究中的其他主角不同，他其实从未与梅兰妮交谈过。他说，那个世界里的许多老跨性别女性，他会在会议上见到，或者她们在他为研究而加入的 Facebook 群组里非常活跃。他其实从未与梅兰妮交谈过。他说，那个世界里的许多老跨性别女性，他会在会议上见到，或者她们在他为研究而加入的 Facebook 群组里非常活跃，但梅兰妮没有。她给人的感觉就像是一个突然出现、在八年时间里显得无比重要的人。而我却不知道她去了哪里。我们想要寻找到梅兰妮，并与那些使用过她录像带的人交谈，但首先我们得找到那卷录像带本身。卡斯其实从未见过它。
So she was one of the main characters on Cass's radar. And weirdly, she kept coming up. Like, I would read like a biography of someone who came out in the early 2000s, and then they would mention the same person. So I was like, oh, weird. Like, clearly, she was like a big deal. But unlike the other main characters in Cass's research, he'd never actually spoken to Melanie. He said a lot of the older trans women from that world, he would see at conferences, or they'd be active on Facebook groups he was in for his research. He'd never actually spoken to Melanie. He said a lot of the older trans women from that world, he would see at conferences or they'd be active on Facebook groups
他只是听说过。但他觉得这不是什么问题。毕竟，互联网上有一个庞大的跨性别档案馆，人们在上面扫描了同人志、通讯刊物，甚至还有各种随机人物的剪贴簿。但当卡斯去寻找《梅兰妮在说话》（Melanie Speaks）——这卷在所有这些通讯刊物上做广告的视频时，它却踪迹全无。我能找到的最接近的东西是一个老旧的网站，它基本上就是该视频的一个广告。而且那个网站有着浓厚得不得了的“炽天使（Angelfire）”和“地球城（Geocities）”时代的风格。接着，卡斯搜索了世界上最大的图书馆目录，
he was in for his research, but not Melanie. She just seems like somebody who dropped in was like so important for like eight years. And I didn't know where she went. We wanted to track down Melanie and talk to people who had used her tape, but first we had to find the tape itself. Cass had never actually seen it.
找到了仅此一册的《梅兰妮在说话》。它藏在康涅狄格州的一家图书馆里。拿到录像带后，我们想要采访那些在 90 年代真正使用过《梅兰妮在说话》的女性。格温·史密斯就是其中一位女性。当时的格温，就像任何一个 90 年代的酷女孩一样，听了大量女性唱作人的歌，并练习跟着唱。“破碎的小药丸（Jagged Little Pill）”和许多萨拉·麦克拉克兰的歌都在播放列表里。我也倾向于听很多梅丽莎·埃瑟里奇的歌，勇敢而疯狂。还有凯蒂·朗，天哪，一直在听凯蒂·朗。
He just heard about it. But he figured it wouldn't be a problem. After all, there's a huge trans archive on the internet where people have scanned zines and newsletters and even like random people's scrapbooks. But when Cass went searching for Melanie Melanie speaks, this video that's advertised in all these newsletters, it was nowhere to be found. And the closest I could find was this like old website that was basically like an advertisement for the video. And the website was like huge like angel fire, geocities Energy. Next cast searched the largest library catalog in the world
艾森·约尔德，直到今天我依然对那张专辑爱不释手。还有果酱乐队（Go Live）、格雷维（Gravy）、格雷维。格温是在一个在线聊天室里了解到《梅兰妮在说话》的。但请记住，这是 20世纪 90 年代的互联网。聊天室里只有纯文本。你没法随随便便上传视频。于是，格温通过普通邮寄信件订购了属于她的《梅兰妮在说话》。如果你想订购一卷这盘录像带，请寄 20 美元。只要 20 美元，包邮。目前只提供 VHS 录像带。
and found exactly one copy of Melanie Speaks. It was at a library in Connecticut. Once we had the tape, we wanted to talk to women who actually used Melanie Speaks back in the 90s. One of these women was Gwen Smith. At the time, Gwen was, like, any cool 90s chick, listening to a lot of women singer-songwriters and practicing singing along. Jagged little till and a lot of s'mores said, was in the playlist. I also tend to listen to a lot of Melissa ethyr just brave and crazy. And Katie Lang, God, Katie Lang constantly.
在此之前，我对跨性别事物的全部了解，都来自于书本上或报纸头条里的人物。其中许多人以各自的方式相当富有或家境优渥，或者至少给人这种印象。而我当时只是一个朝九晚五上班的年轻人，心想：好吧，以我目前在这个世界上的处境，我甚至能做到这一点吗？
The Aishan Yuald, I still adore that album today. And go, live, gravy, gravy. Gwen read about Melanie Speaks in an online chat room. But remember, this was the 1990s internet. The chatrooms were text only. You couldn't just upload a video. So Gwen sent for her copy of Melanie Speaks via snail mail. If you want to order a copy of this tape, send $20. That's all it costs $20. post paid. VHS only is available at this time.
在录像带中，梅兰妮向像格温这样的女性给予了坚定不移的肯定：“你能做到这一点。”只要学会这套小小的日常练习，我就能成为我一直想成为的一切。你可能会发现，花两周时间才能找到它，也可能需要花一个月时间去摸索，但相信我，听我的，这是值得的。我认为梅兰妮的录像带，无论以何种方式，都已经成为许多其他人谈论声音的基础。我知道，我曾把从那些录像带中学到的一些东西教给别人，试图以此来
Up until that point, any knowledge I had about things trans was people that were in a book or were in a newspaper headline. And a lot of these individuals were fairly wealthy or well off in their own ways or at least projected that and me being at that point a fairly young person who is working just a nine to five feeling like, well, can I
帮助他们改善声音。我确信，随着时间的推移，还有许多其他人也在代代相传这些知识。在距离格温数千英里之外，另一位名叫达拉斯·登尼的女性也在使用这盘录像带。达拉斯住在田纳西州纳什维尔，在十几岁刚出头时就开始穿着女装外出了。我会去图书馆，去大楼底层，去百货公司，去商店，去电影院，去看电影，外出吃饭，坐公交车，我化着全妆。如果没戴假睫毛，我都觉得自己没穿衣服。
even do this from where I am in this world? In her tape, Melanie offered an emphatic, yes, you can do this to women like Gwen. I could be everything I always wanted to be just by learning this little routine. What you found it may take you two weeks to find it, may take you a month to find it, but believe me, listen to me, it's worth it. I think Melanie's tape, one way or another, has become the basis for a lot of other people talking about voice. I know that I've taught people some of the things that I learned off those tapes to try
所以我多年来一直琢磨着，我是不是只是在自我感觉良好？我当时真的很像顺性别女性，所以我会做一些这样的事：在百货公司的结账队伍里买一条裙子，然后问他们能不能看出我其实是个男人。尽管达拉斯十几岁时就戴着假睫毛、买裙子，但直到 38 岁时，她才接触到更大的跨性别社群。也就是在那时，她听说亚特兰大有一个跨性别互助小组，距离她当时在田纳西州居住的地方大约有 250 英里。
to help them with their voice. I'm sure there are a number of other people that just pass on some of that knowledge over time. Thousands of miles away from Gwen, another woman named Dallas Denny was using the tape too. Dallas lived in Nashville, Tennessee and started going out in women's clothing in her early teens. I would go to the library, to lower, to the department, to the stores, to the movies, out to eat, ride the buses, I had full fates on. I didn't feel like I was dressed if I didn't have false-night lashes.
最终，在寻找了与自己相似的人 25 年之后，她找到了他们。最终，这个社群引导她接触到了《梅兰妮在说话》。达拉斯记不清自己具体是在哪里听说这盘录像带的了，但她估计是在一个互助小组或会议上。达拉斯对梅兰妮的方法颇为欣赏的一点是，她并没有把自己或她的方法看得太严肃。另一种方法是直接进入那种声音，有点像上一种那样。就像你在说，是的，我是一名纽约市的化学品司机。
So I was wondering for years would I just be seeing myself? I was really passing, so I would do things like buy a dress and check out line at the department store and ask them if they could tell I was really in a kind. Even though Dallas was wearing false eyelashes and buying dresses as a teenager, she didn't encounter the larger trans community until she was 38. That's when she heard about a trans support group in Atlanta, about 250 miles from where
天哪，纽约市的口音里还带着中西部口音。哦，他原本来自中西部。她滑稽的声音让我意识到，如果你想要改变现状，你就必须跳出你的舒适区；还有什么比彻底放飞自我、用声音做出你能做出的最离奇的事情，然后再把它一点点收回来、直到你找到一把新钥匙更好的方法呢？好吧，我得这么做。你把声音降到这里，然后你听上去就像那种典型的南方海湾口音，然后你可以
she was living at the time in Tennessee. Finally, after 25 years of searching for people like her, she found them. And eventually that community led her to Melanie Speaks. Dallas doesn't remember exactly where she heard about the tape, but she figures it was at a support group or a conference. One thing Dallas appreciated about Melanie's approach was that she didn't take herself or her methods too seriously. The other way is to go directly into that voice and go kind of like the last one. Like you're saying, yeah, I'm a New York City chem driver.
说，“哎呀，现在天气变温和了，不是吗？”但接着你把它再稍微放大一点，然后你就可以脱口而出：“不，这简直太奇妙了，不是吗？”但接着你把音调再稍微提高一点，然后你就可以变成典型的美国声音。美国女性在 90 年代的标志性声音。我真的很喜欢她所倡导的理念，即经历一个对声音的探索阶段，因为我认识的很多人都拒绝这么做，因为他们觉得这会让他们听上去很傻，或者听上去像个同性恋。
And gosh, there's a Midwest accent in the New York City. Well, he came from the Midwest originally. Her silly voice has made me realize that if you're going to change things, you have to get out of your zone and what better way to do it than to go on all the way out there with the most bizarre things you can do with your voice and then reeling it back in until you find a new door. Well, I have to do that. You can get down here and then you sound like the typical Southern Bay of, and you can
达拉斯认为，这种担心听上去很傻或像个同性恋的恐惧，阻碍了女性寻找她们真实的声音，但这也是一种合情合理的恐惧，因为在 90 年代，被当成顺性别者看待被认为是至关重要的。在当时，我们应该要能“以假乱真”。每个人都渴望蒙混过关。没有人觉得通不过也没关系。所以我们
say, al-back now it's just mild, isn't it? But then you bring it out even a little bit more, and then you can just out like, no, it's just marvelous isn't it? But then you bring it up a little bit more, and then you can just be typical American voice. The American woman's 90s voice. I really like what she was advocating about, just going through a phase of exploration with the voice, because a lot of the people that I knew were just refusing to do that because they thought it made them sound silly or gay.
互相辅导，专业人士也指导我们完善外表和声音，这样——嗯，主要是为了让我们保持安全，但也是为了能找到工作，让我们不会遭到嘲笑、殴打或杀害。达拉斯提到的这些建议她隐瞒跨性别身份的专业人士，他们是医生，遵循着当时被称为“哈里·本杰明护理标准”的指南。医生批准你接受激素治疗的要求之一，就是一项名为“现实生活体验测试”的规定。
Dallas thinks this fear of sounding silly or gay held women back from finding their true voices, but it was also a legitimate fear to have, because in the 90s, passing as cisgender was considered imperative. At the time, we were supposed to pass. Everyone inspired to pass. No one thought about being okay, not to pass. And so we
我们的制作人卡斯再次登场。你必须在目标性别中生活——比如你试图展现的性别——整整一年，然后才能真正开始接受激素治疗。如果你仔细想想这意味着什么，意思就是你根本不被允许做任何能够帮助你在那种性别中体验生活的事情。你不被允许使用可能会让皮肤变软的激素，可能会
counseled one another and we were counseled by professionals to perfect our appearance and our voices so that, well, mostly so we would be safe, but also to be employable that we would not be ridiculed or beaten or killed. These professionals Dallas mentions who were counseling her to hide her trans identity. They were doctors, doctors who were following guidelines that were then called the Harry Benjamin standards of care. One of the requirements for a doctor approving you to take hormones was this thing called the real life experience test.
帮助胸部发育的激素，可能会帮助你——我不知道，可能会改变你的发际线，或者所有这些完全不同的事情。但你仍然必须走进这个世界，比如穿着那个性别的服装，或者比如你仍然必须走进这个世界，比如穿着那个性别的服装，或者试着以那种身份找到一份新工作——有太多极其艰难的事情要做，而与此同时，你基本上得不到任何帮助来让你的身体呈现出它需要呈现的外观，或者它应该呈现的外观，或者人们期望一个身体呈现的外观。对于在 90 年代经历“现实生活体验测试”的跨性别女性来说，在没有医疗辅助的情况下（再次强调，在完成测试之前她们根本无法获得医疗辅助），她们能做的女性化自身形象的唯一样事情之一，就是进行声音训练。这就让我们回到了那卷录像带——《梅兰妮在说话》。梅兰妮的录像带赋予了她那一代的跨性别女性按自己的方式说话的许可，并向她们展示了如何以一种有趣、迷人的方式做到这一点。这不是一个医生或心理学家在命令你墨守成规。这是另一位跨性别女性在向你展示她是如何做到的。从很多方面来看，《梅兰妮在说话》也是时代的产物。从腹黑女孩开始。走着瞧。我去找了我男朋友，他可没用勺子糊弄我。
Here's our producer, Cass again. You had to live in your target gender, like the gender that you were trying to express for a year before you were able to actually take hormones. And if you think about that for like two seconds, what that means is you're not allowed to do any of the things that would help you experience life in that gender. You're not allowed to have hormones that might soften your skin that might
这简直糟透了。这太有趣了。我有点陷入了一种奇怪的、说不出话来的状态。这是布里安娜·辛克莱，一位跨性别女性兼专业女高音歌唱家。布里安娜从未为了说话做过声音训练。她天生就有很高的音域。但她是一位受过古典训练的歌唱家，所以在声音方面她绝对是个行家。
like help you grow your chest that might help you I don't know, it might change your hairline or like all these different things But you still have to go out into the world and like where are the clothing of that gender or like you still have to go out into the world and like where are the clothing of that gender or like try to have a new job as that like like so much like intense stuff to do while you're also getting basically no help making your body look the way it needs to look or the way it should look or the way people expect a body to look. For trans women undergoing the real life experience test in the 90s, one of the only things they could do to feminize their presentation without medical assistance, which, again, they couldn't
她听说过梅兰妮，但从未看过这卷录像带，所以我放给她看了。我们要讨论的第三个领域是动态范围。它能产生那种让女性声音更具女性特质的“歌唱般的效果”。我们将讨论你是如何思考它的。你在想什么？我是说，这很有趣。这有点像歌剧演员通常的学习方式。比如，你寻找我们声音的极限，在歌剧中我们在低音
get until they completed the test, was voice training. Which brings us back to the tape, Melanie Speaks. Melanie's tape gave trans women of her generation permission to speak on their own terms, and it showed them how to do it in a fun, inviting way. This wasn't a doctor or a psychologist ordering you to conform. It was another trans woman showing you how she did it. Melanie Speaks is also, in many ways, a relic of its time. Start with belly girl. Walked for sure. I went and saw my boyfriend didn't get me with a spoon.
音域中寻找极限。所以，我是说，她某种程度上是对的。但布里安娜并不喜欢梅兰妮录像带的每个部分，比如下面这段，举个例子。请记住，在我们的社会中，男性被训练得更具攻击性。例如，一个男人会说，我要这么做。
It was just like grody to the max for sure. This was very interesting. I'm kind of in like a weird, like speechless place. This is Brianna Sinclair, a trans woman and professional soprano. Brianna has never done voice training for speaking. She naturally has a high register. But she's a classically trained singer, so she definitely knows her stuff when it comes to voice.
而一个女人会说，我在想我或许应该这么做。在这里，在快餐店里，一个男人走到小喇叭盒前说，我要一个巨无霸。而一个女人走到同一个喇叭盒前说，请给我来一份小沙拉。我只是在想，对于使用这卷录像带的跨性别者来说，
She had heard of Melanie, but she'd never seen the tape, so I played it for her. The third area we're going to cover is dynamic range. It gives that sing-song effect that makes the feminine voice more feminine. And we'll cover how you think it. What are you thinking? I mean, this is interesting. That's kind of like how opera singers normally study. Like, you find the limits of our voice and the opera and we find the limits in our bottom
他们的想法会是什么样的？就像她说的那样，我正在努力制造刻板印象。声音中存在着美，我认为世界让声音决定了什么是男性的，什么是女性的。声音可以做到任何事情。我们只是生活在一个充斥着如此二元化概念的世界里。你说话声音高，你就是个女人；你说话声音低，你就是个男人，就这么简单。
register. So, I mean, she's kind of right there. But Breonna wasn't a fan of every part of Melanie's tape, like this section, for example. Remember, in our society, men are trained to be aggressive. For example, a man would say, I'm going to do this.
每个人类都应该体验自己声音的不同音色，与之嬉戏，看看它是什么感觉。但作为一名歌剧演员，有时布里安娜也会依赖性别刻板印象来让角色栩栩如生。当我听到一个清脆的声音时，它确实有一种典型的、英雄般的声音，就像一架铃鼓。它有一种非常英雄般的铃鼓质感。有点像迪士尼王子。
And a woman would say, I was thinking that I ought to do this. And here, that fast food rest from solid time, a guy comes up to the little speaker box and he says, I want a big Mac. And a woman comes up to the same speaker box and says, I'd like a small salad, please. I'm just wondering what it would be like
（《风之舞》音乐响起）好的，那钢琴先生呢？哈哈哈哈。哇，所以钢琴师经常受到调侃，因为他们认为我们很轻浮或有点神经质。天哪，我会因为这个挨揍的。我真不想问，但你对此有什么共鸣吗？
for trans folks who utilize that tape, what are their thoughts? I'm like her saying, I'm trying to produce the stereotype. There is beauty in vocal sounds and I think the world has made the voice determine what's masculine and what's feminine. The voice can do anything. We just live in a world of such binary concepts. You speak high, you're a woman, you speak speak low, you're man, that's it.
这是一个令人尴尬的问题。是的，有时候，我的朋友们知道我有时候可以很轻浮。我可以——哦天哪，我有时可以非常轻浮。对布里安娜来说，这些歌剧般的嗓音是角色，甚至是套路。但你在日常生活中使用的声音，即你的说话声音，是专属于你个人的。这可能是被你的社群接纳和被排斥之间的区别。令人悲伤的是，我们生活在一个大部分都充满对跨性别社群仇恨的世界里。我们的声音确实对我们在世俗中的处境产生了巨大的影响，比如遭遇阻挠或在医疗保健中受到不尊重。
Every human being should experience different timbres of their sound and play with it and see what it's like. But as an opera singer, even Breonna sometimes relies on gendered stereotypes to bring characters to life. When I hear a tin of voice, it really does have a typical,
这周围有太多的层面。就梅兰妮而言，至少在视频中，她似乎知道她谈论什么是女性化、什么不是女性化时所用的方式，并非真的在为这个事业提供帮助。这是她为了让跨性别女性感到安全和舒适而做出的一种牺牲。现在，请相信我，我知道这与女权主义背道而驰，
heric sound, like a tambourine. It's very hero-like tambourine to it. Kind of like a Disney Prince. ["Dance of the Wind"] Okay, and what about Mr. Piano? Ha-ha-ha. Wow, so Piano's we get jokes a lot because they consider us ditty or thing. Oh my god, I'm going to get beat up for this. I hate to ask, but do you relate to that at all?
我也知道这种做法不利于将其革除。但这卷录像带探讨的主题不是如何打破这些刻板印象。它首先探讨的是如何成为一个刻板印象。听到这里，你可能想知道，梅兰妮在哪里？
That is an embarrassing question. Yes, at times, my friends know that I could be ditzy a lot. I could be, oh my god, I could be very ditzy sometimes. For Brianna, these operatic voices are characters, tropes even. But the voice you use in your everyday life, your speaking voice, is specific to you. And it can be the difference between being accepted in your community and being shunned. It's sad that we live in a world most of it's full of hatred in regards to the trans community. Our voice does make a huge impact on how we remove it in the world, getting clogged or disrespected healthcare.
她现在对这一切作何感想？这正是我们想要知道的。从始至终，当我和卡斯寻找录像带、采访达拉斯、格温和布里安娜时，我们也在寻找梅兰妮，而她并不是那么容易找到的。我从事这种 80 年代和 90 年代的跨性别历史研究有一段时间了，
There's so many layers around that. For her part, at least in the video, it seems like Melanie knows that the way she talks about what's feminine and what's not isn't exactly helping the cause. It's a sacrifice she makes to help trans women feel safe and comfortable. Now, believe me, I know this is a nathema to feminism, Now, believe me, I know this is a nathema to feminism, and I know that this is something that is bad to perpetuate. But this tape is not about the subject of how to break those stereotypes. It's first about how to become one. By this point, you're probably wondering, where is Melanie?
我在让人开口说话方面取得了非常成功的进展。所以我开始翻阅我那本较老的跨性别女性通讯录，给人们发电子邮件，结果却屡屡碰壁。卡斯也问过历史学家、从事档案工作的人，但都无济于事。我们还得知梅兰妮拥有一家出版剧本创作软件的公司，所以我们也联系了他们。没有人回复我们。我们怎么知道梅兰妮还活着？部分答案在于我们可以看到她的社交媒体。她有一个公开的 Facebook 个人资料，但它更像是一个粉丝专页，所以你无法向她发送好友请求。
What does she think of all this now? And that is exactly what we wanted to know. This whole time, while Cass and I were looking for the tape and talking to Dallas and Gwen and Brianna, we were also looking for Melanie, and she was not easy to find. I've been working on like trans history of this sort of like 80s and 90s for a while, and I've been working on trans history of this sort of like 80s and 90s for a while and I've had like really good success getting people to talk. So I started going through my like older trans women role-adex and emailing people and like kept striking out.
梅兰妮还是一位多产的自出版作家，在我们的搜寻过程中，我们可以看到她每隔几个月就会在亚马逊上出版新书。既然卡斯从她以前的朋友和商业伙伴那里没有打听到什么消息，他决定一头扎进梅兰妮的大脑中。最让我回想起的一件事，是我小时候第一次拿到《指环王》的副本时，心想：这是有史以来最大的一本书，而且它竟然有三本该死的大厚书。梅兰妮在 2018 年出版了一本庞大的回忆录，就像《指环王》一样，它分为三卷。卡斯开始阅读。真正引人入胜的是，作为回忆录，它们非常独特且怪异。它们
Cass also asked historians, people doing archival work, no dice. We'd also learned that Melanie has a company that publishes screenwriting software, so we reached out to them too. No one got back to us. How did we know Melanie was still alive? Part of the answer is that we could see her social media. She has a public Facebook profile, but it's like a fan page, so you can't send her a friend request.
不一定按时间顺序排列。它们非常具有联想性。它们会透露出关于编写者本人的蛛丝马迹，但常常会掩盖其他细节，比如它们会写道：“我住在树林里，”而你会想：“究竟是哪片树林？”卡斯读这本大部头可不只是为了好玩。他在寻找线索。我试图寻找她提到风景或地名的地方，这很有帮助，然后它告诉我，她不想住在城市里，因为她不想让别人打扰她。我想：噢，原来如此。所以，那是——所以那是最初的迹象之一，我真正开始觉得，噢，也许发生的事情并不是我们一直用错电子邮箱。也许发生的事情是这个人
Melanie is also a prolific self-published author, and during our search we could see her publishing new books on Amazon every few months. So since Cass wasn't having any luck with her former friends and business partners, he decided to dive headfirst into Melanie's brain. The thing that reminds me the most of is when I first got a copy of the Lord of the Rings as a child and was like, this is the biggest book of all time, it's also three fucking giant books. Melanie published an enormous memoir in 2018 and like the Lord of the Rings, it has three volumes. Cast started reading. What's really fascinating about them is that they, as memoirs, are really unique and strange. They're
根本不想和像我这样的人说话。到了这个时候，我们已经走投无路了。我们给梅兰妮发了无数封电子邮件，在多个社交媒体平台上给她发了消息，但都没有回复，而且现在有了时间上的压力，因为我们非常确信梅兰妮住在加利福尼亚州。而我正在加州为另一个故事进行采访之旅，而且我还没有订回程机票。所以我正呆在我在伯克利的爱彼迎民宿里，我正在加州为另一个故事进行采访之旅，而且我还没有订回程机票。所以我正呆在我在伯克利的爱彼迎民宿里。我完全进入了“记者模式”，在房间里转圈踱步，每隔五分钟就给卡斯打一次电话，说道：“我们需要找到梅兰妮，
not necessarily chronological. They're very associative. They drop hints about the person who is writing them, but are often obfuscating other details so they'll be like, I lived out in the woods and you're like, what woods? Cass wasn't just reading this tome for fun. He was looking for clues. I was trying to find places where she mentioned like landscape or mention locations, and that was helpful and then it told me that she did not want to live in the city because she did not want people to bother her. And I was like, Oh, no. So that was, so that was one of the first like indications that I really, where I really started to feel like, Oh, maybe what's happening isn't that we keep having the wrong email address. Like maybe what's happening is this person
否则我就得订回家的机票了。”就在这时，卡斯取得了突破。他一直在加州为梅兰妮查询公共记录请求，
just like does not want to talk to people like me. By this point, we're getting desperate. We've sent Melanie a ton of emails, we've message her on multiple social media platforms, no response, and now there's time pressure, because we are pretty sure that Melanie lives in California. And I am in California on a reporting trip for another story, and I have not booked my return flight. So I'm in my Airbnb in Berkeley, I am in California on a reporting trip for another story, and I have not booked my return flight. So I'm in my Airbnb in Berkeley. I'm in like full reporter mode pacing around in circles, calling Cass every five minutes, being like, we need to find Melanie
结果显示：梅兰妮曾在以下这五个城镇居住过。但随后卡斯注意到，还有另一个梅兰妮，有着不同的姓氏，记录显示她也曾在所有这些相同的城镇居住过。当我们搜索那个带有不同姓氏的梅兰妮时，我们找到了梅兰妮的个人 Facebook 账号，而不是我们之前看到的那个专业的粉丝专页。从那里我可以看到所有这些她和她整个家人的照片。我能看到她的孩子。我能看到她的孙辈。所以我们之前掌握的名字一定是个职业名、笔名，也许是娘家姓，而她现在结婚了。新名字也让我们对梅兰妮可能在哪里有了更清晰的了解。我们当时已经到了这种地步：
or I need to book my flight home. This is when Cass has a breakthrough. He's been running public records requests for Melanie in California. and the results say like, Melanie has lived in these five towns. But then Cass notices that there's another Melanie, with a different last name, who's showing up as having lived in all the same small towns. And when we search the Melanie with a different last name, we find Melanie's personal Facebook account, not the professional fan page we'd
这是她最近的五个住址。我很确定这些都是对的，因为它们是出现在这个我们知道是真名的新名字之下的地址，而且它们出现得足够连贯，可能不仅仅是数据聚合错误。所以他们会想，哦，她可能在那里呆了一段时间，然后她又去了另一个地方。我们就真的像是在绘制梅兰妮的《指环王》地图那样不断缩小搜索范围。到了这个时候，我心想：好吧，管它的。我们知道那个城镇。我要开车去那里。我要敲开一扇扇门。我会找到她的。但卡斯开始感到不安。我当时的想法是：听着，为了尾随这位年长的跨性别女性，我付出了这么大的努力。而她
seen before. From there I could see all these pictures of her with her whole family. I could see her kids. I could see her grandkids. So the name we had must have been like a professional name, a pen name, maybe a maiden name, and now she's married. The new name also gives us a much clearer picture of where Melanie might be. We were at the point where I was like,
在每一步都刻意隐藏了自己的行踪。我经常看到记者在对待跨性别者时越界，并假定关于你自身的某种程度的透明度会对社群有好处，或者能让我们更多地了解你所经历的事情。而其中很多并不能让公众了解真相。它只是让跨性别者再次受到创伤。并且它不理解的是，当跨性别者隐瞒关于自己的某些事情时，这并不是在鬼鬼祟祟。
here's her last five addresses. I'm pretty sure these are right because they're the ones that appear under this new name that we know is the right name, and they're the ones that appear consistently enough that they probably not just data aggregation errors. And so they're like, oh, she probably was there for a while, and then she went to this other place. Like we really were like honing in on like making that like Lord of the Rings map of Melanie. At this point, I'm like, all right, fuck it. We know the town. I'm gonna drive there. I'm gonna knock on doors. I'm gonna find her. But Cass was starting to feel uneasy. I just was like, listen, I've worked so hard to like creep on this older trans woman. And she has
这只是一种生存机制。我不认为敲别人的门本身有什么有害的。但我认为，随着我们越来越接近打破她那层小小的防护罩——打破她的泡泡，我越发觉得这并不妥当。是的。当时我们正看着她的家庭照片，感觉非常……既然我们已经找到了真名，确实感觉像是闯入了某种她并不希望我们进入的泡泡。
intentionally covered her tracks in every step of the way. And I see journalists a lot like overstep with trans people and presume that a certain amount of like transparency about yourself is going to be good for the community or like tell us more about what you've gone through. And a lot of that doesn't inform the public. It just retraumatizes trans people. And it doesn't understand that when trans people are hiding something about themselves, it's not like being shady.
是的，这就好比另一个名字就是她一直在寻找的树林里的小屋。这是她远离聚光灯、给自己一些平静和喘息空间的方式，而我当时脑子里唯一能想到的、那种心头一紧的感觉就是：我不想再追捕这个人了，天哪，有多少跨性别女性能够拥有那个树林里的小屋？我们社会中有多少跨性别女性能够在生命中找到片刻的平静与安宁？我理解卡斯的感受，但我希望梅兰妮亲自说“不”。我想确保她知道我们在找她，而且我不想在没有她的情况下讲述她的故事。
It's just a survival mechanism. And I don't think there's anything inherently harmful about knocking on someone's door. But I think that like, though closer we got to kind of like breaking her little shields, like breaking her bubble, the more I started to feel like that was not okay. Yeah. And we were at that point where we were seeing her family photos, it felt very... We had found to a real name, it did feel like we had broken into some bubble that she didn't want us to.
如果有哪怕一丝可能，她会愿意成为其中的一部分。我们给梅兰妮的个人 Facebook 账号发了私信。在 Facebook 上，你可以看到消息是否已被打开，而我们的消息并没有被打开。但我们也给梅兰妮的一个孩子发了私信，那条消息被打开了。对我和来说，这就足够了，因为这被她的孩子看到了，如果换作是我，
Yeah, it's almost like that other name is the cabin in the woods she was looking for. It's her way of staying out of the spotlight and giving herself some peace and some respite and like all I could think of when I was like feeling that gut feeling of like I don't want to hunt this person down anymore is oh my gosh like how many trans women get to have that cabinet in the woods? How many trans women in our society get to find peace and quiet ever in their lives. I understood where Cass was coming from, but I wanted Melanie to say no herself. I wanted to be sure that she knew we were looking for her, and I didn't wanna tell her story without her.
我会把它转给我妈妈。那个孩子也有可能没转。不过，我们俩都在梅兰妮那天发布的帖子下进行了评论，那是一个她似乎经常查看的页面。并不是说有几百万人在评论。所以，应该只有我们在评论。我相当确信她知道
If there was any chance, she'd wanna be a part of it. We'd messaged Melanie on her personal Facebook account. On Facebook, you can see if a message has been opened and ours hadn't been. But we'd also messaged one of Melanie's children and that message was opened. This was why it was enough for me, was that it was seen by her kid who, if it were me,
我们在找她，这种程度让我觉得不去她家也可以。我们两个在道德上也一致认为最好不要开车去她家。是的，是的，我想那是对的。而且我的意思是，我觉得——我只是不想派一个随机的非跨性别记者去敲她的门。
I would send it to my mom. It's possible that the kid didn't. But also, we had both commented on posts that Melanie had made like that day, on a page where she seems to be checking it all the time. It's not like there are a million people commenting. Like, it would be just us commenting. I feel pretty certain that she knew
坦白说，如果发生那种事——那种情况完全是另一部电影。那就好比是这样一个场景：一个跨性别者正处于这个国家有史以来最严重的基于媒体的跨性别恐惧症的时期。拿着麦克风去你家——如果我是那个跨性别者，我会想：“这个人是福克斯新闻的派来的，
we were looking for her, enough that I felt okay about not driving to her house. And we both ethically agreed that it was best to not drive to her house. Yeah, yeah, I think that's right. And I mean, I think that like, I just didn't wanna send a random non-transjournalist talking on her door.
我马上要被谋杀了。”我当时会想：“这个人是福克斯新闻的。我快要被谋杀了。”我会非常害怕。所以，与其说“嘿，去穿上你所有的广播装备，对这个人进行‘连环杀人案风格’的敲门采访，”你知道的，或许如果是做那种连环节目、我们在调查一桩真实的谋杀案，我们可能真会这么干。但问题的关键不是这个人是否被不公正地监禁。问题的关键是：是谁制作了这卷录像带？甚至都不是“是谁制作的”，我们知道是谁制作的。
It was like, to be honest, like, when that had, like that, like that's a whole different movie. Like that's the movie of a trans person in a moment of some of the most acute media-based transphobia that this country has ever seen. Like going to your house with a microphone, like if I were that trans person, I would be like, this person is from Fox News,
对，没错。更像是：他们作何感想？对，没错，没错，问题的关键是：你对这件事有何感想？我们从未与梅兰妮交谈过。相反，为了了解她对《梅兰妮在说话》可能会有什么样的感受，我们转向了她于 1994 年写的一篇文章，并邀请跨性别艺术家兼表演者卡达·莫尼尔来朗读梅兰妮的一些文字。
I'm about to get murdered, I would be like, this person is from Fox News. I'm about to get murdered. I would be really scared. So yeah, rather than be like, Hey, go put on all your like radio gear and do like serial style door knock of this person, you know, like, and maybe we would have done it if it was serial and we were investigating a actual murder. But the stakes are not is this person unfairly imprisoned. The stakes are like, who made this video tape? Like, not even who made it, we know who made it.
突然间，我意识到在整个变性过程中，我一直在向遇到的每一个人说我曾经是个男人。我甚至在钱包里随身带着一张蓄着胡子的男人的老照片，随时拿出来震惊别人。我挺享受这一点的。对我来说，这是衡量我成功与否的标准，看看他们有多震惊。每次发生这种情况，我都为自己感到骄傲，感到自己成就非凡，感到自己与众不同。问题恰恰出在这里，如果我把自己的“与众不同”建立在曾经是个男人的基础上，那么那个男人将永远是我的一部分。梅兰妮在想，她是否需要
Right, exactly. It's more like, how do they feel? Right, yeah, yeah, the stakes are, how do you feel about this thing? We never talked to Melanie. Instead, to get some clues about how she might feel about Melanie's speaks, we turned to an article she wrote in 1994, and we asked Carda Monier, a trans artist and performer, to read some of Melanie's words.
彻底忘记自己的过去才能向前迈进，但事实并非完全如此。我并不是想忘记我曾经是个男人。我是想忘记当一个男人的感觉是什么样的。梅兰妮意识到，每当她掏出那张老照片时，她都在重新唤起那些感受，于是她决定不再这样做了。我许下承诺，开始说谎。我不再向新朋友或熟人分享我的故事。有些人会通过机缘巧合或从别人那里发现真相，但他们绝不会从我这里得知。当我谈起我的过去时，我不再用“当我还是个孩子的时候”来缓和真相，而是会大言不惭地说：“当我还是个小女孩的时候”，并且发自真心。因为，尽管从逻辑上讲这可能是一个谎言，但在情感层面上，它是上帝对真理的坦诚。在逻辑层面上，这是上帝对真理的坦诚。卡达，这位朗读了梅兰妮文字的表演者，对她的感受感同身受，尽管这些文字是在三十年前记录下来的。感觉就像是在分享我自己的经历的一个版本，尽管显然有很多细节被改动了。跨性别经历中确实有一些元素——尤其是在渴望被视为真正性别这方面——是相当具有永恒性和普遍性的。卡达将梅兰妮视为跨性别女性互帮互助的一个缩影，
Suddenly, I realized that all through transition, I had been telling everyone I met that I used to be a guy. I even carried an old photo of bearded man in my purse to whip out and shock people. I enjoyed that. To me it was a measurement of my success as to just how shocked they were. Every time it happened, I felt so proud of myself, so accomplished, so special. And therein lies the problem, if I based my specialness on having been a man that man would always be a part of me. Melanie wondered if she needed to
尤其是当传统的资源无法提供帮助时。看着她，我说：她不过是一个录制视频并把它们发到虚空中的女性。就像在录像带里，她说：我不是医生。我不知道这样说话长期下去会不会伤害你的喉咙。我完全不知道，你知道吗？这就是所有跨性别事物背后的那种感觉。就像是：这是对我有用的方法。我完全不知道它会怎么样，你知道的，所以别再问我更多问题了。这就是我所知道的全部。
forget her past entirely in order to move forward, but that wasn't quite it. I didn't want to forget that I was a man. I wanted to forget what it felt like to be a man. Melanie realized that every time she pulled out that old photo, she was bringing up those feelings, so she decided to stop. And I made a commitment to begin to lie. No longer will I share my story with new friends, or acquaintances. There are some who will find out, either by circumstance or from others, but they will not find out from me. When I speak of my past, I will no longer temper the truth by saying,
也许对梅兰妮来说，制作录像带是她表达“别再问我更多问题了，这就是我所知道的全部”的一种方式。接受我们的播客采访，可能意味着要记起她宁愿继续遗忘的那一部分自我。甚至在 90 年代制作视频时，梅兰妮就已经在暗示，变性前后的对比根本不是她想再分享的事情。了解我是如何改变的。但过了一段时间，我达到了这样一个临界点：那个旧角色和旧身份不再是我的一部分，也不再合适了。有时，我们用声音能做的最有力量的事情，
when I was a child, but will bold-faced state, when I was a little girl, and mean it. Because, although it may be a lie in terms of logic, it is God's honest truth in terms of logic. It is God's honest truth in terms of feelings. Carta, the performer who read Melanie's words related to her feelings, even though they were recorded three decades ago. It feels like I'm sharing a version of my own experience, although obviously with a lot of details changed. There are elements of the trans experience, especially when it comes to wanting to be perceived as your proper gender that are fairly timeless and universal. Cardicee's Melanie as an example of the ways trans women take care of each other,
就是保持安静。但在梅兰妮的沉默之中，成百上千在 20 世纪 90 年代看过她的录像带、在互助小组里将它在女性之间传递、或者将 20 美元支票寄往社区通讯刊物边缘上找到的地址的人们，
especially when traditional resources fail them. I look at her and I say like, she is one woman making video tapes and kind of setting them out into a void. And like, in the tape, she says, like, I'm not a doctor. I don't know if talking like this is going to hurt your voice long term. I have no idea, you know? And that's the feeling behind so much of trans stuff. Just like, this is what works for me. I have no idea what it's going to, you know, like, don't ask me any more questions. This is as much as I know.
那些人找到了她们的声音。你在哪里唱歌呢？你会在淋浴时唱歌吗？你做家务时会唱歌吗？
Maybe for Melanie, producing her videotape was her way of saying, don't ask me any more questions. This is as much as I know. Speaking to us for a podcast might have meant remembering a part of her, she'd just as well keep on forgetting. Even when she made the video back in the 90s, Melanie was already hinting that the before and after of transition just wasn't something she wanted to share anymore. get an idea of how I've changed. But after a while, I reached the point where that old role and that old persona is no longer a part of me and no longer appropriate. Sometimes the most powerful thing we can do with our voice
这里又是格温·史密斯。在淋浴时唱歌，做家务时唱歌，工作时唱歌。有时必须确保如果我在打电话时别唱出来。但，是的，音乐无处不在。在她的写作中，梅兰妮一直在与这种想要将过去抛在脑后的渴望作斗争。她甚至称之为不诚实，并说道：
is stay quiet. But in the midst of Melanie's silence, hundreds of people who watched her tape back in the 1990s, who passed it from woman to woman in their support groups or sent a $20 check to an address they found in the margins of a community newsletter. Those people found their voices. And where do you do you sing in the shower? Do you sing doing chores?
“我许下承诺，要开始说谎。”但她也说，将自己表现为另一个普通的女性，与伴侣生活在一起，享受漫长的远足，拍摄野花的照片，这是上帝对真理的坦诚。为了做到真实，没有人必须暴露自己的全部面貌。但如果我们不分享像《梅兰妮在说话》这样的历史档案，整整一代酷儿和跨性别者将不会知道他们的前辈是如何建立社群的。那是跨性别群体还处于……的年代
Here's Gwen Smith again. Sing in the shower, sing doing chores, sing while working. Have to sometimes make sure I'm not if I'm on phone calls. But yeah, I mean, music is omnipresent. In her writing, Melanie wrestles with this desire to leave her past behind. She even calls it dishonest, saying,
这是格温·史密斯。在淋浴时唱歌，做家务时唱歌，工作时唱歌。有时得确保自己在打电话时没唱。但对，我的意思是，音乐无处不在。梅兰妮在她的写作中，一直在与这种抛弃过去的渴望作斗争。她甚至称之为不诚实，并说：
I made a commitment to lie. But she also says it was God's honest truth to present herself as just another woman, living with her partner, enjoying long hikes, and taking pictures of wildflowers. No one has to reveal all the parts of themself in order to be authentic. But if we don't share artifacts like Melanie Speaks, a whole generation of queer and trans people won't know how their elders created community. This was back in the days before trans people
“我做出了说谎的承诺。”但她也说，将自己表现为另一个普通的女人、与伴侣同居、喜欢长途徒步并拍摄野花，这是绝对的大实话。没有人必须展露自我的所有部分才能做到真实。但是，如果我们不分享像《梅兰妮诉说》这样的作品，整整一代酷儿和跨性别者将不知道他们的前辈是如何建立社群的。这回到了跨性别者出现之前的日子
could find each other on Pokemon Discord servers or fighting about Marxism on Twitter or wearing pronoun buttons at the farmer's market. Trans people were already telling their own stories 30 years ago and long before that too. It makes sense that Melanie herself might not want a linger in that period of trans history, but we want to make sure the next generation has the choice to remember it. And anyway, there's no way to fully erase the tape.
可以在宝可梦的 Discord 服务器上找到彼此，或者在推特上争论马克思主义，或者在农夫市集上佩戴代词徽章。跨性别者在 30 年前甚至更早以前就已经在讲述他们自己的故事了。梅兰妮本人可能不想在跨性别历史的那段时期过多停留，这是可以理解的，但我们要确保下一代有选择记住它的权利。无论如何，磁带是无法被彻底抹去的。
Even if the last copy breaks down over time, as all old tape eventually does, Melanie's influence will endure. The advice and encouragement she gave will ripple down to future generations. It already has. This is Dallas Denny playing her original song, Dark Old Wind. It now then moves, it never tells us where it's never still. How it once, how it will. Sounds Gay is created and produced by me, Sarah Esacuff. Our story editor is J.TT Green of Molten Hard. Cassadair is our consulting producer, additional editing by Gianna Palmer.
即使最后一份拷贝随着时间推移而损坏，正如所有老旧磁带最终的结局一样，梅兰妮的影响力也将永存。她给予的建议和鼓励将对后代产生深远的影响。这已经发生了。这是达拉斯·登尼（Dallas Denny）在演奏她的原创歌曲《黑暗的老风》（Dark Old Wind）。它现在开始流转，从不告诉我们它从不停歇的地方。它曾如何，它将如何。《同性之声》（Sounds Gay）由我萨拉·埃萨库夫（Sarah Esacuff）创作和制作。我们的故事编辑是 Molten Hard 的 J.TT Green。卡萨代尔（Cassadair）是我们的顾问制作人，吉安娜·帕尔默（Gianna Palmer）参与了后续剪辑。
Original music by Chris McCormick, mixing in sound design by Casey Holford, fact checking by Serena Solen. Our program manager is Sam Termine. Sounds Gay is a stichre studio's production and is executive produced by Sarah Bentley, Bill Crandall, Jen Durwin, Mike Spanella, Camille Stanley, and myself. You can find Sounds Gay on the serious XM app, Pandora, Stitcher, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you like to listen. If you like the show, please rate, review, and share so other people can find us. That dark o'er. More about voices with me and special guest, Roman Mars, after the break.
原创音乐由克里斯·麦考密克（Chris McCormick）创作，混音与声音设计由凯西·霍尔福德（Casey Holford）完成，事实核查由塞雷娜·索伦（Serena Solen）负责。我们的节目经理是萨姆·特米内（Sam Termine）。《同性之声》是 Stitcher 工作室的制作，执行制片人为萨拉·本特利（Sarah Bentley）、比尔·克兰达尔（Bill Crandall）、简·达尔温（Jen Durwin）、迈克·斯潘内拉（Mike Spanella）、卡米尔·斯坦利（Camille Stanley）以及我自己。你可以在 Sirius XM 应用、潘多拉（Pandora）、Stitcher、苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）或你喜欢收听的任何地方找到《同性之声》。如果你喜欢这个节目，请评分、评论并分享，以便其他人能找到我们。那黑暗的……休息过后，我和特邀嘉宾罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）将探讨更多关于声音的话题。
We're back. And joining me in the studio is none other than Roman Mars. Hey, Roman. Hey, Swan. How you doing? I'm doing great. It's so nice to be a guest on 99% Invisible. I enjoy it immensely. Yeah, yeah.
我们回来了。加入我工作室的正是罗曼·马尔斯。嗨，罗曼。嗨，天鹅（Swan）。你好吗？我很好。很高兴能做客《99%无形》（99% Invisible）。我非常喜欢。是啊，是啊。
You don't get to do that too often, I think. Did you enjoy the episode? I did. I love this story. And when I first heard it, I knew it would be good for us. But I also knew that I wasn't the person to comment on it, that it only made sense if you hosted the show. And I appreciate that. And I, I've really enjoyed hosting. And yeah, I, I really, I really enjoyed the episode. There were a lot of things about it that, you know, that
我想你平时不常这么做。你喜欢这一集吗？我很喜欢。我非常喜欢这个故事。当我第一次听到它时，我就知道它很适合我们。但我也知道我不是发表评论的最佳人选，只有当你来主持这个节目时才最有意义。我很感激这一点。而且，我真的很享受主持的过程。是的，我真的很，真的很喜欢这一集。里面有很多事情，你知道的，
did touch me and sort of like made me think a little differently and like made me reflect on my own experience in a way that I appreciated. Yeah, that's great. And I think that something that really jumped out at me especially was that part in the end about sisterhood, about how trans women take care of each other when traditional resources fail them because Because that's all the time. Like, you know, like I spend most of my time around other trans women. And there are so many big and small roadblocks that were up against all the time.
确实触动了我，让我有了不同的思考，并以一种我所感激的方式反思了我自己的经历。是的，这太棒了。我觉得有一个特别让我印象深刻的地方，就是最后关于姐妹情谊的那部分，讲的是当传统资源无法提供帮助时，跨性别女性是如何互相照顾的，因为因为那是一直都在发生的事。就像，你知道的，我大部分时间都和其他跨性别女性在一起。我们一直都在面对着大大小小各种各样的阻碍。
And obviously there's like, you know, like, understanding that we can give each other than no one else can. But like, the queer community are also like the first to show up for each other when we're facing things like job discrimination and housing discrimination when we need, you know, like, help recovering from surgery or money from surgery. You know, it's like when insurance isn't covering stuff. I mean, that's so nice to hear that that you all do. It's, it's so nice to hear that you all do.
显然，你知道的，我们可以给予彼此那种别人无法给予的理解。但是，当我们面临诸如工作歧视和住房歧视等问题，当我们需要（你知道的）手术恢复帮助或手术资金时，酷儿社群也是最先为彼此挺身而出的人。你知道的，就像保险不报销某些东西的时候。听到你们所有人都在这么做，真的感觉太棒了。听到你们所有人都在这么做，真的太棒了。
It's always sad to hear that it's out of a kind of necessity because no one else does. But you take care of me, Ronald. Thank you. That wasn't a prompt, but I appreciate it. No, I mean it. I mean it. Well, while we're sharing this sort of personal experience
听到这一切源于某种必需，因为没有其他人会这么做，总是让人感到难过。但你在照顾我，罗曼。谢谢你。这不是提示，但我很感激。不，我是认真的。我是认真的。好吧，在我们分享这种个人经历的同时，
and I was hoping that you could share some of your voice training experience. How did you navigate that yourself? Yeah, I had insurance coverage for a speech-language pathologist. And speech pathologists are doctors who work with patients who, you know, like have had like vocal hemorrhages or other kinds of like neck injuries and stuff, you know, people with speech impediments and they, you know, it's like it's speech therapy. And so, you know, some speech pathologists also take on trans clients, women, men, non-binary, you know, to help them actualize their voices. But
我希望你能分享一些你的声音训练经验。你自己是如何应对的？是的，我的保险涵盖了言语语言病理学家（speech-language pathologist）的费用。言语病理学家是与患者合作的医生，你知道的，比如那些经历过声带出血或其他各种颈部损伤的人，你知道的，还有患有言语障碍的人，而且他们，你知道的，这就像是言语治疗。所以，你知道的，一些言语病理学家也会接受跨性别客户——女性、男性、非二元性别者，你知道的，来帮助他们实现他们的声音。但是，
and men non-binary, to help them actualize their voices. But the hangups that come with this is that this person who was teaching me was a cis woman and being corrected on my gender presentation vocal wise or even being applauded for speaking like quote more femininely by this cis woman. While her authority is that she's a speech pathologist and she's commenting on this process that we're undergoing, that dynamic of her being cis and commenting on how my gender is perceived. I just can't help but resent that dynamic.
男性、非二元性别者，来帮助他们实现他们的声音。但这带来的困扰是，这位教导我的人是一位顺性别女性，当这位顺性别女性纠正我的性别呈现（在声音方面），甚至为我说话听起来“更女性化”而鼓掌时。虽然她的权威身份是言语病理学家，并且她正在对我们正在经历的过程发表评论，但那种她是顺性别者却在评论我的性别如何被感知的那种动态关系。我就是无法不对这种动态关系感到怨恨。
I mean, as well intention as that speech, pathologist might have been, that she was friendly and she was real nice. It must have been really frustrating. Because you want to connect with people who know everything goes on to it, not just like where your epiglottis is or something like that. Like you want a real sense that they understand what you're going through. Yeah, because it's way more than just a physical process. It's
我的意思是，无论那位言语病理学家的初衷有多好，她很友好，人也非常好。那一定真的很令人沮丧。因为你想和那些了解全貌的人交流，而不仅仅是知道你的会厌在哪里之类的人。就像你希望他们能真正理解你的经历一样。是的，因为这远不止是一个生理过程。它
extremely a psychological process, but that's why it's so important that you have someone who really gets that aspect of it, that psychological part of it, and then has care for it. And so what is the equivalent today of the Melanie Speaks tape? I've seen, actually, you present some of your voice training online. And is there a bunch of that out there? of your voice training online. And is there a bunch of that out there? Yeah, I mean, there are a lot of like women who go through their processes. And because of this age that we live in, you know, there's like this whole wide range
极其心理化，但这就是为什么拥有一个真正理解这一层面、理解心理部分并给予关怀的人是如此重要。那么，今天有什么可以与《梅兰妮会说话》的磁带相媲美的东西吗？实际上，我看到你在网上展示了一些你的声音训练。那外面有很多这样的内容吗？你的声音训练在网上。那外面有很多这样的内容吗？是的，我的意思是，有很多女性在经历她们的过程。由于我们生活的这个时代，你知道的，有各种各样
of like Melanie speaks type stuff going on all the time. And I had a lot of friends to talk about this stuff with in Pokemon Discord servers, like the story mentioned, in voice training Discord servers, and on my Twitch channel, which I started, because I sounded like fun to play video games for people and hang out, but I'd also stream my voice practice on my Twitch channel, like to keep me accountable. And to have people tell me I'm hot, you know, like let's not get ourselves. Of course. And, you know, I'd go
像《梅兰妮会说话》那种类型的音频一直在不断涌现。正如节目中所提到的，我有很多朋友可以在宝可梦的 Discord 服务器、声音训练的 Discord 服务器以及我的 Twitch 频道上讨论这些事情。我创建 Twitch 频道是因为我觉得为人们玩电子游戏并和大家一起闲逛会很有趣，但我也在 Twitch 频道上直播我的声音练习，以此来监督自己。并让人们夸我辣，你知道的，让我们别自欺欺人了。当然。而且，你知道的，我会
through my voice exercises and I'd sing songs. And then I'd select something to read in my stereotypy straight girl voice. Like, for example, here, the screenplay from the Matrix. What the hell do they want with me, Neo asks? Mortpia says, I'm not sure. But if you don't want to find out, you better get out of here. Neo says, how? I can guide you out.
进行我的声音练习并唱歌。然后我会选择一些内容，用我刻板的直女声音朗读出来。比如，在这里，电影《黑客帝国》（The Matrix）的剧本。尼奥（Neo）问：“他们到底想从我这得到什么？”墨菲斯（Morphious）说：“我不确定。但如果你不想知道，你最好离开这里。”尼奥说：“怎么离开？”我可以带你出去。
But you have to do exactly what I say, like a good girl. He doesn't say that. The agents are moving quickly. That's great. Especially using the matrix as the sort of like modern, uh, trans text of our time. Mm-hmm. Our godmother is the Wachowski sisters. Yeah. And ramen you might have noticed
但你必须完全照我说的去做，像个好女孩一样。他没这么说。特工们正在快速行动。这太棒了。特别是把《黑客帝国》当作我们这个时代的某种现代跨性别文本。嗯哼。我们的教母是沃卓斯基姐妹（Wachowski sisters）。是的。罗曼，你可能注意到了
that my voice sounds a little different there than it does right now. Yeah. And so it not to be like the speech pathologist or some sort of curious, look-y-loot type of person who's like not sensitive to these things. Explain that to me. Explain to me, we're voice therapists, you're voice when you're speaking to me now. I mean, part of it is that thing that Melanie says in the video about embodying a stereotype was a large part of my process. And it's the kind of thing that it's like, all the while, I felt like a little resentful of. But really the like stereotype woman voice, you know, the, my name means money. Many more men than women on the moon. That kind of stuff is like, you know, my voice really changed because I was like
我的声音在那里听起来和我现在听起来有点不同。是的。所以，为了不表现得像个言语病理学家或者那种对这些事情不敏感的好奇吃瓜群众。给我解释一下。向我解释一下，我们是声音治疗师，你现在对我说话时的声音。我的意思是，部分原因就像梅兰妮在视频中所说的那样，体现一种刻板印象占据了我整个过程很大一部分。而且那种感觉就像是，一直以来，我都对此感到有点怨恨。但实际上，那种类似刻板印象的女性声音，你知道的，“我的名字意味着金钱。月球上的男人比女人多得多。”诸如此类的事情就像是，你知道的，我的声音真的发生了改变，因为我当时在
having fun with that and putting on this extreme. Yeah. And I was talking to a friend the other day about this though, and her perspective on it that I that I really liked was she was like, I mean, yeah, but that's that's what everyone does. That's like, you know, that's what we all do as little kids is that we put on extreme versions of a voice of like something we saw on TV or in a cartoon or something. And we just kind of like, we mimic it, we have fun with it, you know, and then our voices set from many, many different things.
从中寻找乐趣，并表现出这种极端的声音。是的。不过前几天我和一个朋友谈过这件事，她对这件事的看法我非常喜欢，她是这么说的：“我的意思是，是的，但这就是每个人都会做的啊。”就像是，你知道的，这就是我们所有人小时候都会做的事，我们会模仿电视上或动画片里看到的某种声音的极端版本。我们只是有点像，我们模仿它，从中获得乐趣，你知道的，然后我们的声音由许多许多不同的事情共同塑造而成。
And it's just that like with voice stuff that I started thinking about a lot because of my voice training and seeing like other people go through this process is that like there's actually no voice that is you know uninfluenced by something. And there's no voice that's fixed. Like there's no voice that doesn't change. I mean, you know, the stakes are different individual experiences are always different. This is sort of the caveat we always have in this discussion. But literally everyone on Earth has gone through
只是关于声音的事情，因为我的声音训练以及看到其他人经历这个过程，让我开始思考很多，那就是实际上没有任何声音是（你知道的）不受任何事物影响的。也没有哪个声音是一成不变的。就像没有哪个声音是不会改变的。我的意思是，你知道的，赌注是不同的，每个人的经历也总是不同的。这就是我们在讨论中总是要加上的限定条件。但字面意义上，地球上的每个人都经历过
voice transitions, and they've navigated it with a certain type of consciousness and subconsciousness. But everyone's voice has changed over time, and have chosen different paths for it to go on. And it's just like, it's a universal thing that people go through. Yeah. Everybody makes these decisions consciously or unconsciously anyway. And I mean, like, you know, Roman, I even recall hearing like an, you know, an old episode
声音的转变，并且他们带着某种意识和潜意识去应对它。但随着时间的推移，每个人的声音都发生了变化，并且为它选择了不同的发展道路。这就像是人们都会经历的一种普遍现象。是的。无论如何，每个人都会有意识或无意识地做出这些决定。我的意思是，就像，你知道的，罗曼，我甚至还记得听到过一个（你知道的）旧节目，
like from like, you know, the start of like 99 PI and really just like being struck by how different your voice is from there to where it is now. Yeah, I mean, it was a real, I mean, it's sort of a mix of conscious, and unconscious like you're saying, you know, like if you go back and listen to old episodes, you will notice the difference and people have made me aware, but they notice the difference. And I just have this job where I hear my voice all the time, notice the difference and people have made me aware, but they notice the difference.
比如从（你知道的）《99%无形》刚开始的时候，真的就（你知道的）对你的声音从那时到现在的变化之大感到震惊。是的，我的意思是，这真的很真实，我的意思是，这有点像是有意识和无意识的结合，就像你说的，你知道的，如果你回去听以前的节目，你会注意到差异，人们也让我注意到，他们注意到了差异。我只是有这样一份工作，我必须一直听到自己的声音，注意到差异，人们也让我意识到这一点。
And I just have this job where I hear my voice all the time, so you naturally begin to craft the parts of it that you find pleasing and you sort of like lean into those parts. And also working with a microphone is a very unnatural. And so this thing is like four inches from my face. Oh, but it's so fun. I love it.
我只是有这样一份工作，我必须一直听自己的声音，所以你自然会开始塑造那些你觉得悦耳的部分，并且你有点倾向于那些部分。此外，使用麦克风是一种非常不自然的事情。所以这个东西离我的脸大约有四英寸远。哦，但它太有趣了。我爱死它了。
I love the sound of voices on a microphone, but like it's very different than navigating the world. I'm talking pretty softly. In the world, my voice has a little bit more of a nasal register higher, just so it can get further than about three feet. You know, funny to me how it's a little bit of both of those things. It's a little bit of me thinking about it and trying to make the most pleasing sound possible with my voice because it's what I find subconsciously pleasing and what I get rewarded for for sounding a certain way. But also, I'm just older.
我喜欢麦克风里声音的质感，但这与在现实世界中穿行非常不同。我说话的声音其实挺轻的。在现实世界中，我的声音会带有一点更高的鼻音共鸣，这样才能传得比三英尺更远。你知道的，我觉得有趣的是，这其实是这两者的结合。这既有一点我内心的思考，试图用我的声音发出最悦耳的声音，因为这是我在潜意识里觉得悦耳的，也是我因发出某种声音而获得回报的方式。但同时，我也只是变老了。
I'm like 20 years older. It's kind of all those things together. It's this swirl of, you know, conscious choices, unconscious choices, you know, the fact that my job is broadcasting, you know, all those sort of things swirl together to create the voice that I have, which is a voice that feels like me, even though parts of it are chosen. You know what I'm saying? Yeah, everybody makes choices. It's, you know, and we choose the things because of who we are, you know. I think it's great. I mean, so much of what
我老了20岁。差不多所有这些因素加在一起。这是一种交织，你知道的，有意识的选择、无意识的选择，你知道的，我的工作是广播，所有这些事情交织在一起，塑造了我现在的声音。这是一个让我觉得就是我自己的声音，尽管其中有些部分是经过选择的。你知道我在说什么吗？是的，每个人都在做出选择。这就是，你知道的，我们选择这些事情是因为我们是谁，你知道的。我觉得这很棒。我的意思是，很大程度上
that you're sort of trained for this in broadcasting or acting is because you are so used to the idea that you have to work very hard to get to the point of being natural. Because as soon as you're in front of people and in front of a microphone, it immediately makes things unnatural and weird and nervous and stuff.
你在广播或表演中接受过这方面的训练，是因为你已经非常习惯这样一种观念：你必须付出非常大的努力才能达到自然的状态。因为一旦你站在人们面前，站在麦克风前，它立刻就会让一切变得不自然、奇怪、紧张之类的。
And so you have to do all this effort to sound just like yourself. And I think that there's a metaphor here. I think that it's even more direct than a metaphor. It's like, this is something that, you know, that I got hung up on in my voice training and that like most girls I know get hung up on is like, you know, they're just like, is this my voice?
所以你必须付出所有的努力，才能听起来就像你自己。我觉得这里面有一个隐喻。我觉得这甚至比隐喻还要直接。这就好像，这是（你知道的）我在声音训练中纠结过的事情，也是我认识的大多数女孩都纠结过的事情，你知道的，她们就会想：“这是我的声音吗？”
Like, do I sound natural doing this? And it's like, you know, like, is it inauthentic that I'm doing so much work to sound natural? And it's like, no, this is normal. This is just, this is part of, this is part of it. It is part of the human condition. To what you put on, what face you put on further. People, what is part is you, how much of that is you
这样做我听起来自然吗？这就好像，你知道的，“我付出了这么多努力才听起来自然，这难道是不真实的吗？”然后答案是：“不，这是正常的。这只是，这是其中的一部分。这是人类生存状态的一部分。”你展现了什么，你进一步在人们面前展现了什么面具，哪一部分才是你，其中有多少是真正的你
that goes into it. I mean, it's just everyone should and can relate to all this. It's just what it is to be a human in the world. Yeah, it's so true. And it's like not everyone could be literally in danger if they can't put on a certain voice like out at the liquor store or whatever. But that's something that I started thinking about a lot also and think about all the time still is that my old voice before training is something that I chose.
融入其中。我的意思是，每个人都应该并且能够对所有这一切感同身受。这就是作为世界上的一个人所意味着的一切。是的，这太真实了。这就好像，并不是每个人在去酒铺买酒等场合时，如果无法装出某种声音就会面临生命危险。但这也是我开始深入思考并一直在思考的事情，那就是我训练前的旧声音其实是我自己选择的。
And it's something that I chose out of fear. Like I went through my first puberty. I have mixed feelings about that, but that's a different conversation. But, you know, but so like, you know, I went through my first puberty and as my voice was shifting, I made this very conscious effort to speak lower, to speak more staccato, to speak monotone. And sort of like, you know, like a little, a little like key part of, you know, my voice feminization training was being like, oh, it's not that I'm learning to speak like a girl.
那是我出于恐惧而做出的选择。就像我经历了我的第一次青春期。我对那段经历有着复杂的感受，但那是另一个话题了。但是，你知道的，所以就像，你知道的，我经历了我的第一次青春期，随着我的声音开始转变，我做出了非常刻意的努力，让自己的说话声音更低沉、更断续、更单调。并且就像，你知道的，比如我声音女性化训练中一个很小很核心的部分就是：哦，并不是我在学习像个女孩一样说话。
It's that I'm unlearning the things that I was doing out of fear. The things that I was just like that I worked really hard at in order to be perceived a certain way, to keep me safe. And the way that I speak now, there's a flow to it that I have found that feels a lot more natural. And that's just like, you know, that's all I want for anybody, honestly. Well, I'm so glad that you shared some of your experience about this and so glad that we got to present this awesome documentary from SoundsK. So glad that you host the show and I could be your guest. I love it. I had a really great time. Thank you, Roman. Thanks
而是我在戒掉那些我出于恐惧而做出的行为。那些我为了被某种特定方式看待、为了保持安全而付出巨大努力去做的事情。而我现在说话的方式，有一种我找到的流畅感，让我觉得自然得多。老实说，这就是我希望为任何人做到的全部。好吧，很高兴你分享了你在这方面的经历，也很高兴我们能够呈现来自《同性之声》的这部精彩纪录片。很高兴你能主持这个节目，而我能成为你的嘉宾。我很喜欢。我度过了一段非常美好的时光。谢谢你，罗曼。谢谢
for having me. What was the choice? You spent years on those boys. They said girls. They said girls. 99% Invisible was produced this week by me, Swan Rale, edited by Vivian Le, sound mixed by Martín González, original music by me, Swan Rale, including this song called Basic Girls. You can find it wherever you stream music. Special thanks this week to Mia Byrne, Jamele San Dodo Senai, Sororl, and V. Viana. Our senior editor is Delaney Hall, Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Barubay, Jason De Leon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Lashemadon, Jacob Aldenado Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, intern Anna Castanero,
邀请我。那是什么选择？你在那些男孩子身上花了几年时间。他们说女孩。他们说女孩。本周的《99%无形》由我，斯旺·雷尔（Swan Rale）制作，维维安·勒（Vivian Le）剪辑，声音混音由马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martín González）完成，原创音乐由我，斯旺·雷尔创作，包括这首名为《基础女孩》（Basic Girls）的歌曲。你可以在任何你听音乐的地方找到它。本周要特别感谢米娅·伯恩（Mia Byrne）、杰梅尔·桑多多·塞奈（Jamele San Dodo Senai）、索罗尔（Sororl）和维·维安娜（V. Viana）。我们的资深编辑是德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall），库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Colstead）是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barubay）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason De Leon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、拉舍马·多恩（Lashemadon）、雅各布·阿尔德纳多·梅迪纳（Jacob Aldenado Medina）、凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、实习生安娜·卡斯塔内罗（Anna Castanero），
and of course. Me, Roman Mars. We'd also like to welcome Kathy too to the team, who is joining us as our new executive producer. We are so excited to have you Kathy. If you'd like to hear more stories like the one in this episode, check out Sounds Gay. Their first season is out now,
当然还有。我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们还要欢迎凯西（Kathy）加入团队，她将作为我们崭新的执行制片人加入我们。凯西，我们非常高兴你能加入。如果你想听到更多类似本集中的故事，请去看看《同性之声》。他们的第一季现在已经上线了，
wherever you listen to podcasts. It's seven episodes, and each episode is a deep dive into a different queer music subculture. There's one where Sarah and Cass go to a trans punk show. There's one about a closeted Christian music star. There's one about a lesbian rap battle feud. Pick the one that most interests you and as far as I'm concerned, all of them should interest you
无论你在哪里听播客。它一共有七集，每一集都深入探讨了不同的酷儿音乐亚文化。其中有一集是萨拉和卡斯去观看一场跨性别朋克演出。有一集关于一位隐柜的基督教音乐明星。还有一场关于女同性恋说唱对决恩怨的节目。挑选一个最让你感兴趣的，就我而言，所有这些都应该让你感兴趣，
and just go from there. The 99% invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We're part of the Stitcher and Series XM podcast family now had quartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in all together now. Beautiful. Uptown. Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 9-9-PI org or on Instagram, Reddit and TikTok too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Okay, I'm gonna do my warm-ups.
然后从那里开始。《99%无形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。我们现在是 Stitcher 和 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，总部设在奥克兰市中心潘多拉大楼以北六个街区的地方。好啦，现在。美丽的。加利福尼亚州奥克兰市的住宅区。你可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与关于该节目的讨论。你可以在推特上@我 Roman Mars，也可以@该节目 @9-9-PI org，还可以在 Instagram、Reddit 和 TikTok 上找到我们。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到我喜欢其他 Stitcher 节目的链接，以及《99PI》过去的每一集节目。好吧，我要开始做热身了。
Sally's sister-streamed Stitcher shows on Sirius XM. serious XM. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Sally's sister-streamed Stitcher shows on Sirius XM. serious XM. 本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。